The Hope Diamond has long been the undisputed star of the museum,...
...but it was upstaged recently at the unveiling of a new gem:...
...the Dom Pedro Aquamarine.
Visitors vied with the media to get a photo of the iridescent obelisk,...
...which stands more than 35 centimeters high and weighs two kilograms.
It is the largest cut and polished gem aquamarine in the world.
Jeffrey Post is curator of the museum's mineral collection.
It's very rare, very unusual for any mineral...
...to produce a crystal the size and the quality...
...that could result in cutting a stone like the Dom Pedro.
And most would be cut into wearable gems like these,...
...and that ultimately would've been the fate of the Dom Pedro,...
...had it not been for wealthy gem collectors Jane Mitchell and her husband Jeffrey Bland.
I thought that would be such a loss,...
...so that's when my husband and I stepped forward and said,...
"Well, we'd like to purchase it."
We had no desire to hold on to it privately.
We felt it should strike awe in as many people as could be...
...because that's how we felt when we looked at it.
That's why they donated the Dom Pedro to the Smithsonian National Museum of Natural History.
With 7.4 million visitors last year,...
Whoa, that's weird.
...it is the most popular museum in the United States,...
...due in large part, to the Hope Diamond.
Now, visitors have another breathtaking reason to come here.
Susan Logue, VOA News, Washington.